Need to do.
So if I could start quickly.
Sure.
Yeah, sure, we can.
Okay.
Uh...
cover Krishna's performance with you and we can cover Sally's when Sophia joins.
Kaila.
Okay. So yeah, because I have to leave shortly. I have the task of a deadline. Okay, so Krishna, I'm happy with her this week. I really am. She's doing more of the AP communication with the vendors.
Sure.
ask me for statements. If she have any questions, like how to do it or what should I have asked, I help her out and she does it. So I have no problem helping her out in any way, shape or form. So I'm happy with that.
I.
It.
Um...
Reid.
Thank you so much.
Yes, I really am, and the vendor board is clean. Well, we have two people on the board, so she's working on the P.O.'s, looking after the vendor's inquiries. We had asked from Manan that regarding QuickBooks that...
S.
She wanted us to extract all the Ingram invoice from the QuickBooks and then save it into the file folder, and it's a big task, so I've asked her to at least put half an hour a day to do that, just to pull it from the Ingram.
in QuickBooks and to save it. So not like that. I don't spend it through every day, but this half an hour a day so that we get that out of the way.
Hello!
Hi, Sofia.
OK.
Oh.
How are you doing?
I'm doing fine, and you?
I'm doing great. Thank you so much.
Right, so we were just discussing with Tammy about Krishna's performance, and she's saying everything is going good.
Tell me, is there anything else that you want to add?
No, no, that's it. Is there anything else that did any questions for me?
Nope, I don't have any questions. Amit sir, do you have any questions?
No, I think, Tammy, I guess you mentioned that you wanted, you had some tasks and you wanted to attend. If you still have some time, we certainly would want to go through the performance side of the things, presenting the slides and going through it. But yeah, if it is not something that you're able to right now, we can certainly send it through over an email and you can take a look at it.
No.
Ohh.
Get back to us.
Sure, yeah, if yeah, if you don't mind, yeah.
Yeah, OK.
Yeah.
Okay, so, so I gotta go, so I do apologize.
No, no problems at all. Wish you a wonderful weekend ahead. Thank you.
Just completely find out.
Okay. Okay. Okay, you too. You as well. Okay.
Thank you, Tammy.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
Blake.
Lang.
It.
All right, Sophia. Yeah, thank you so much for joining in. Before I jump into the presentation deck, how are things going with Sethi?
So far so good, but I just have a question. Today we have...
It's not an incident, but something happened. So we have to work in credit cards payments today. So we divide the work because we have to give the information before 12. So we divide the work. I did the part that charges to the client and she has to apply the payment.
Ch.
For this, we have a file that I created with the transactions and everything. And Sally has to work ConnectWise, Excel, and QuickBooks. So it's the three things that she has to have open. And she mentioned that she couldn't work in the Excel.
Because now that she has the three things open, the internet was failing. So it's something that you're having issues with the internet connection or...
Not at all. We certainly can check if it is a system specific issue because we are all on the same site. Sarbjeet is just about 10 meters away from her. So it could have been one odd situation with her PC maybe, but it is not a widespread issue that I can think of right now.
Mm.
Mhm.
Uh...
Yeah, maybe maybe it's the PC because she she has mentioned a few times now that she has internet issues. Not today, today.
That was yesterday, today, today, yeah. Okay, so we'll have to check, right, Sophie, and get back. But it is not something that we have spread across the site because there are other MSP engineers also working from the same site. We haven't seen anything. It could have been a one-off situation. So we can certainly check and ensure that has.
Bye.
Yep.
PC and system is working as expected.
Yes, please, because we need to keep working like that. Because she mentioned that for this, she has to close Excel and then she has to open again and work again. So she has to do twice the work to double check everything. So that is something that we would like to avoid.
Mm.
Sure, sure.
I'll take care of it.
Yes, please.
Thank you so much. And yeah, let me quickly share my screen, Sophia, and we can go through Sally's work from last week.
Mhm.
Let me know if you're able to see my screen.
Yes, I can see him.
All right, so this is the performance slide for Sally, where she closed 80 tickets during the period of May 21st till 27th, out of which 57 work with book payment applications, 9 work likewise managed tickets, 7 queries, and two credit card payment tickets.
If I talk about the days that had the maximum volume, they were May 22nd and 25, where collectively she worked on 30 good book payment applications, connect voice tickets for 10, 3 queries, and 52 service board updates.
Mhm.
And I guess she also took the initiative to clear the open credit from the client's account. This is something that she's taking accountability to get it done as soon as possible.
Okay, that's good.
Yep.
Any questions or suggestions, Sophia, you have here?
No, the information seems right.
Rick, let me quickly and share my screen.
Yep, this is what we have in terms of our data from the past week. And yeah, I think things are going well with Sally. Yep. So yeah, this is all I have for today. Sarbjeet, do you want to add something?
Yes.
No, I believe we'll be checking it out right away, Sophia. Thank you for bringing this up to our attention.
Okay.
We have.
All right, Amrit.
I think that over well is going really well with Sally.
That's amazing. I mean, there's been a lot of focus overall, Sophia. And I think the credit goes to you. Like I said on the previous call as well, the comfort and the support that you have given, it is reflecting in our confidence. Because of course,
A
Yes, I see that she's more confident doing the things, yes.
Sing.
Yeah, yeah, and it's all you at the end of the day, because, you know, the way you have supported, she's feeling comfortable, confident talking to you, and she has the feeling that she is working under somebody who is supportive, and she is at the same time eager to do more. So I think that is the reason she's able to drive in the right way.
Great.
And I'm sure that such kind of support that you continue to give, she will be one of the best players. And we are, of course, here too. Yeah, absolutely. Brilliant. OK, so we will send over the slide deck so that Temi can also review the second part of the information that we had.
Yeah, I think so.
And in the interim, what we will do, Ashish will just check with internal IT and get a check done to make sure that her system is all set. Yeah, yeah, so that she doesn't face any problems as such.
Yes, please.
Rest up, we are always there on chat. Sophie, as you know, just ping us and we will hop on a call.
That's good.
Okay, perfect. Thank you.
All right, enjoy your weekend and pleasure speaking to you. Thank you. Take care. Bye-bye.
Thank you so much.
You too, enjoy the weekend. Like, bye-bye.
Thank you, Sophia. Goodbye.